look at reynaldo lopez the twins are
familiar with him they've knocked him
out early two starts that he's had
against them so far this year's gonna
feature fastball slider change and you
like this matchup on paper but you don't
play the games on paper you have to go
out there twins had a very good game
last night against giolito but now it
starts all over again today so polanco
is on a two-odd walk let's see if the
twins can capitalize now with nelson
cruz and a 2-2 pitch swing and a miss
strike three inning over a couple of
strikeouts for lopez here in the first
inning
has been everything the twins had hoped
for more they
gave up a really good young arm in the
trade for him but he's doing really well
and he makes life miserable on
right-handed hitters he does not give
them any free passes only one walk to
right-handed hitters so far this year
which is a good sign because you've got
two of the better and two of the hotter
right-handed hitters in all the baseball
here's a guy that is pretty good jose
abreu mvp candidate leads the american
league and hits he leads all the
baseball with 49 runs batted in
grondell on and the pitch of swinging a
line drive to the shortstop fielded by
polanco's second one throws to first in
time that's the double play a one hop
line drive to polanco at short a
backhand pick beating gonzalez for one
on to first and that goes six four three
based his empty two house and now buxton
red hot he's homered in five of his last
eight games one two pitch a drive to
left field and deep back it goes deep it
goes down the line that is fair and go
on a home run for the second time this
season byron buxton has hormone in three
consecutive games a blast on the left
field line and the twins take a
one-nothing lead he knew it off the bat
the only question was whether it was
going to stay fair or foul he kept the
bat alive he followed off some tough
pitches and then got a hang of breaking
ball and he didn't miss it two down for
a former first round pick nick madrigal
pulled the wind up and now the 2-2 pitch
is swinging to fly ball center field
routine byron over to his right back
pedal sunglasses out a cap high catch
and maeda has faced the minimum through
three there's polanco
strike three ronaldo lopez five
strikeouts one hit one walk through
three and a third ronaldo has looked
really good and he's mixing his pitch as
well
two up two down eddie rosario the batter
one nothing twins in the fourth and the
one-one is a high pop-up on the infield
right side
jose abreu yelling i got it i got it i
got it and he does and the inning has
come to an end one two three go to the
twins here in the fourth one nothing
twins in the bottom of the fourth inning
here's a brayu he delivered the only run
last night
that hung around jose hits it in the air
left center field way back there and
gone
he did tie the game jose abreu's case
grows for mvp
and it's one all
right
shaking his head because he made the
pitch last pitch that should have gone
out of the ballpark he made the same
pitch
this pitch and it did go out of the
ballpark and this game suddenly is tied
at one
a slider that doesn't slide two mistakes
in a row the second of which
was home run number 17 as buxton goes up
as far as he could go batter's going to
be byron buxton three straight games
with a home run
he got another breaking ball and he did
the same thing with it
a home run to left buxton's got two
today
and the twins are back in front
when you're that locked in you can smile
when you're running around the bases
it's it's fun to watch him right now
i don't know what's changed or what's
clicked in his swing but he has seen the
ball very well you make any mistake to
him
and that ball ends up in the seats
that's a real big swing right there able
to take the lead back pick up your
pitcher and you see grandahl's target
away 12 home runs for buxton in 109 at
bats and carnacion at the plate after
striking out his first time edwin hits
it in the air left field well struck
this ball game is tied
diana missed right over the middle of
the plate now he's given up eight home
runs the parrot has come out
accompanying edwin around the bases
and just like that yet another long ball
these are two heavyweights going
head-to-head both landing a couple of
haymakers all right so tim anderson to
the plate does set up away and the pitch
a ground ball third base donaldson
fields it comes up throwing in time
to get
anderson
here's lopez facing josh donaldson with
the twins trying to retake the lead
that's a strike two and one a much
needed strike and donaldson's not gonna
like it well he can't believe it first
of all
he's really giving it to dan bellino
and then this
deep down the left field line home run
donaldson with a solo home run and the
twins have hit three against lopez this
afternoon
he tossed him they just tossed donaldson
for kicking dirt on home plate as he
crossed home plate
so now here comes rocco baldali and he's
likely to get tossed too i have never
seen a guy get thrown out after hitting
a home run donaldson obviously fired up
so jose abreu the rbi leader in the
league has runners at first and third
and two down
two and two
of rayo on the ground left-hand side
polanco
jose beat it out
this ball game is tied abrayu another
two-strike rbi
and now eloy jimenez rips one down the
left-field line the sox are going to
take the lead gilmer sanchez scores and
loy's got a surprise for sergio romo and
it's four to three
and the 2-2 pitch a fly ball got jam
popped up
back of right here comes kepler coming
on gonzalez makes a wonderful sliding
catch out of nowhere kepler came in to
know gonzalez went out marwin sliding
snow coning scooping and makes a
wonderful play throughout number two
one
out away from a white sox playoff spot
first pitch swing
in the air
luis robert
makes the catch and in a year
when so many of us have had to be a part
we all will journey together into
october with the white sox
for the first time in 12 years the sox
are going to the playoffs